[Music]
Madeline you are not the only parent
complaining just by far the loudest okay
Melissa I don't even like to chew I just
shove them down maybe you can give one
hand Warren so if you can shut it - oh
and we're off
it's a classy crop Imams these ones
people think that I am unhinged pretty
much that one she's the Medusa Monterey
I put squish you like the bug that you
are what second grade begin
[Music]
I still feel responsible for the
accident it's gonna get us it's gonna
get us all wait
why this detective is just trying to be
the pressure on us that one of us breaks
you don't believe my son just slipped
[Music]
he knows that I lie to him we swallow
our feelings especially the bad ones
pegye turn into really ugly monsters do
you see yourself as a monster
[Music]
I can just see the damage that's done
and it's eroding every single one of us
my son is dead and I want answers why
can't you answer is but you left some
things out didn't you you were planning
to leave him and you learned if his
infidelity just 10 seconds before he
died
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you